- You got a new tattoo
since last time I saw you,
can I see it?
- The last one was probably
one of the things from the golden record.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- And the first one,
- [Kelly Clarkson] What's the first one?
- which is also science-related is this,
- [Kelly Clarkson] That looks
like Mission Impossible code.
- Right? So, right before I turned 40,
I was like, "I'm gonna do it."
I've wanted them for so long.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- I went on that show,
"Finding Your Roots".
Do you know that show?
- Oh! No, but I did something like it.
- Okay.
- "Who Do You Think You
Are?" I did something that,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, so, somewhere where they like,
- Yeah.
- do your DNA,
- do those genealogy things.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- So, I thought, "Right,
well, whatever they teach me,
I'll get my first tattoo".
And I went on that show thinking like,
"I wanna find out that
I'm a third Scottish
and I can get a family crest."
(Kelly laughing)
Yeah, you all are
laughing 'cause you know,
(audience laughing)
but you know what I
mean, like, in your head
(Kelly laughing)
I'm like, "There's gonna
be something cool."
- Yeah. There's gonna be something random.
- All those commercials say that
you're gonna find out something random.
- Yeah (laughing).
- So, I do the show and
six months later, you go in
and they film everything and they go,
"You are 99.9% South
Asian. How do you feel?"
(Kelly laughing)
(audience clapping)
- And I just blurted out like,
- You are 100% that bitch.
- literally I was like, yeah, exactly.
(audience clapping)
(Kelly laughing)
I was like, "Yeah, I know.
It's so disappointing."
They're like,
"Oh, you're disappointed in who you are?"
And I'm like, "No, no,
that's not what I said."
- Don't quote me (laughing).
- But they did show me this
map with number, "R1a-M147",
- which is a maternal haplogroup
that you share with millions
and millions of other people,
and it's basically your DNA ancestry.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh!
And I was like, "That's
gonna be my first tattoo."
- That's super cool!
- 'cause it's science.
- Yeah.
- Now, that said, I then went
and bought my own DNA testing kit
to see what else was in there.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- And that came four months after that,
and I'm on my computer, logging in,
and
- Oh no.
I see that maternal haplogroup,
which I have tattooed at that point,
that says, "R1a-M147",
- Is not?
on the computer it says, "R1a-M417".
(audience laughing)
- Oh,
- You all are laughing.
You're so gleeful aren't you?
- my, I am.
- My partner, Josh, was home at the time,
and I was like, "Dude, come over here.
What is the deal with this? R1a-"
- [Kelly Clarkson] Is this real?
- Is this real?
And the gleeful look on his face.
(Kelly laughing)
Like, I have never seen him happier
and just be like, "Ha, ha, ha!".
(Kelly laughing)
And then I emailed them all, and you know,
it was like, "Yo, what's the deal,"
- [Kelly Clarkson] How dare you?
- Yeah, but now I kept it,
'cause it's a good story.
- My first tattoo is a
Japanese Kanji character
and they said, it means "blessed",
and then I was like,
"Yeah, that's awesome."
I was like 18-years-old. I
was like, "This is cool."
- [Kal Penn] Yeah. Yeah.
- My place had just burned down,
I wasn't in it,
so that's a blessing,
- [Kal Penn] Yeah, totally.
- and so, I love irony,
and so I literally got it done,
and when I went to Japan,
I was literally like,
"Please dear God, tell
me this means 'blessed'".
(Kal laughing)
I was like 21 and they were
like, "It means 'blessed'
but it also means like someone's surname",
it's a family name.
(Kal laughing)
So, I just have like someone's
family name on my body.
It's fine.
(Kal laughing)
We make really good decisions at 18.